it used to be so simple you were a boy
or you were a girl but that was then and
this the next battleground transgender
right is NaN born both a boy and a girl
as we find ourselves in the myths of a
gender revolution she's like I'm not a
boy I'm a girl in my heart my brain
there are areas in the brain that
correlate with gender identity when
Ellie yes then your son said that it's
at a little scary
and then the doctor came over he said
well sometimes babies are not quite a
girl and not quite a boy she would need
surgery
these are human rights violations on
intersex kids bodies
there's evidence that seems to show
trans brains are in fact different and I
use he/him/his I use they/them there I
am plural this is not just one
individual but a whole group of kids at
times do you feel like whoa whoa whoa
it's too fast it's all it's making me
dizzy
what about your mom and dad do they call
you Brian now they're coming D do you
wish they'd call you Brian yes
[Music]
a lot of us don't even have the stress
to report a crime well I want to empower
all the women like us
[Music]
your case is going to be heard before
the Supreme Court I'm looking for the
same opportunities that my peers enjoy
every single day and that includes using
the same restroom
[Music]
I said goodbye bill and she became Kate
if he was off someone you're willing to
do what it takes
there are people in these societies they
recognize more than two genders
we're all a lot more complicated than
[Music]
you
[Music]